[Music]
and
what brings charles des veuves
to this room today he is a
man just like any other just like any
other
not quite yet this
difference goes back to an origin
that is common to us all
its life like ours began in the
cell to fertilize a tiny
spark of life a cell with
potential one believe to believe
dividing
from one to two
from two to four by the
fundamental process of mythos
8 13 and so  immediately and the cell
becomes andrillon
[Music]
seventh week and the embryo is made up
of thousands of cells grouped according to
their character and which evolves into tissue
there cable
this one for the hand
[Music
] others for the
eye  still others for the heart
and the embryo the adult unnerves
balanced complete and the expansion of the
cells does not stop
and if it does not stop
if the cells start to grow again
to multiply without faith or law
betraying the  organization they  nt
part she crosses blindly
beyond all normal
[Music]
they invade healthy tissues and
organs they infiltrate the
whole organism where they establish their
colonies malling
[Music]
it's cancer
in the
pancreas cancer  is an evil as old
as history and which can appear in
any living organism
it is the problem in two words of a
cell which for no apparent reason
starts to grow again without stopping we
know that
but why and how to stop it
largest brains in the whole world
and it is to answer these two
essential questions
but why and if not why the
answer escapes us tel
it is because this tiny cell where
the answer hides this
microscopic unit escapes it to the naked eye
c  It's more than a world to explore, it's
a universe where
science sinks into this universe where
it discovers new
constellations which it erects where
all the avenues of research
converge towards  this secret point the
cell
because in this head of the pines where
worlds hide
lies the mystery of life and the enigma
of cancer
[Music]
in a vacuum a particle of flesh on
beat researchers know how to
keep it alive well  after the animal
is dead so that normal tissues and
cancerous tissues can be
compared under
certain
conditions experimentation on living tissues
is fundamental but it is a
delicate problem to keep them alive they
must be fed in  a
sterilized atmosphere under
constant temperature and humidity conditions
these tissues can also grow
in areas where they feed on
the embryo
by experimenting on living tissues
the scientist seeks clues that will
explain the abnormal behavior of
these cells
the ultimate goal is to stop this
growth
from destroying it
the biochemist
attacking the problem on the other hand
studies the way of life the cells  the she
breathes under the eye of the scientist who
analyzes the gases inhale and exhale
in his laboratory the scientist scrutinizes
his enemy seeks the defect in the
breastplate the weak point which will make it possible
to stop this growth malignant on
his side genetics has revealed
by  continual crossbreeding of
entire families of mice which can be said for
sure that they will have cancer
this is what is called pure lines
men of course are neither
mice nor descendants of pure lines
and nothing proves that  cancer is
hereditary in humans but
the study and 13 hereditary in
pure lines may be able to lead to
the cure of mouse cancer then
a human cancers
but all this research all this
accumulation of details what does such
for charles davis mean does it mean  that
now healing is not
impossible what we have learned we
can already use it death said
give up entire territories this  th
year the majority of cancer cases
studied all will be successfully treated
the x-rays they attack the
cancerous cell like giant hammers
advances with great strides
ever more powerful radiation devices
come into service day
by day
the  geiger counter
measurement wipes through the organism the course
of radioactive october 6th these compounds
which go in search of
outlaw cells and the study inside
the silent and invisible radium
becomes 116 more powerful and more precise
these destructive rays locked up in  a
thousand skull needles penetrate the
tumor and annihilation
and modern surgery puts at the service
of scientists an ever more
precious weapon to extirpate the
malignant tumors hidden in the body
every day hopes are affirmed
more progress has been made during
the last five years than in the
previous 25 years we can
succeed today from emirates impossible
there is a a  n
today we can say mr
davis more people are cured every
year and the trion men against
cancer the mystery of cancer is constantly asserting itself
but for the scientist that efforts still
the definitive answer is not found
and the  relentlessly continues research
the experiments for smith
every day every night throughout
the night all over the world in the
quiet of the laboratories the tax
patiently pursues stubbornly
by men who spy on the adversary is
getting closer to it scrutinizes his secret
of the men who  restores hope in
life
[Music]